When I sat in front of the computer
I felt like I had superpowers
But people told me I was just wasting my time
When I turned 7
I got parts to build a computer with my Dad
It was mind blowing for me
You know, something, that I built
came to life
When I graduated high school
my parents just told me that
I need to do something that will land me a job
I didn't really know where to go
I gave up on my dreams
of pursuing Computer Science and
eventually I got into Business School
I felt like I was out of place
I felt like it wasn't a good fit
and I knew it wasn't a good fit
Dropping out felt really risky because
I was afraid that
I'm gonna make the same mistake again
Since my parents didn't graduate high school
they just didn't know what was right for me
I found Udacity
It was a good way to learn about
different areas of Computer Science
before I started my studies again
Online learning is really good at
reflecting the market's needs
and you can start with something like web development
and work yourself up to self-driving cars
It's all in the realm of possibilities
and you don't need a degree
and you can do it from anywhere in the world
With Udacity and Google
you build projects which are
interesting for potential employers
When I had my job interview
they looked at the app I built
and they saw what I could do for them
Once I got my certification from Google
it took 3 months to go from
knowing some programming
to landing a job
it's just really a fast track program
to becoming an Android Developer
My work really reflects how I approach things
and seeing people enjoy that
gives me the feeling of being on the right track